solve for x we have 8 times the quantity
3x plus 10 is equal to 28x minus 14
minus 4x so like every equation we've
done so far we just want to isolate all
of the x's on one side of this equation
but before we do that we can actually
simplify each of these sides the
left-hand side we can multiply the
quantity 3x plus 10 times 8. so we're
essentially just distributing the 8
distributive property right here so this
is the same thing as 8 times 3x which is
24x
plus 8 times 10 which is 80 is equal to
and over here we have 28x minus 14 minus
4x so we can combine the 28x and the
minus 4x if you have 28x minus 4x that
is 24x and then you have the minus 14
right over here now the next thing we
can do and it's already looking a little
bit suspicious but just to confirm that
it's as suspicious as it looks let's try
to subtract 24x from both sides of this
equation
and if we do that we see that we
actually remove the x's from both sides
of the equation because we have a 24x
there and we have a 24x there you might
say hey let's put all the x's on the
left-hand side so let's get a get rid of
this 24x so you subtract 24x right over
there but you have to do it to the
left-hand side as well
and then we're left with on the
left-hand side these guys cancel out
you're left with just 80 is equal to
is equal to these guys cancel out as
well is equal to negative
14. now this looks very bizarre it's
making a statement that 80 is equal to
negative 14 which we know is not true
this does not happen 80 is never equal
to negative 14. they are just inherently
in equal so this equation right here
actually has no solution
this has
no solution there is no x value that
will make 80 equal to negative 14.